[Music]
just a couple days ago Google cloud
platform announced the beta launch of a
very useful new tool called the cloud
scheduler firebase developers can use it
to schedule cloud functions to run at a
specific point in time or on a time
interval today you'll learn how to use
the scheduler and I'll also throw in a
few pro tips to make development of
scheduled jobs as smooth as possible if
you're new here like and subscribe and
you can check out the whole source code
on angular firebase com running cloud
functions on a schedule has been one of
the most commonly requested features so
I'm super excited to now be able to do
that there's all kinds of different use
cases for scheduled jobs but what I'm
going to do today is combine it with
Twilio to create a function that will
call my cell phone every five minutes
and remind me to have a good day
in other words we're going to build our
own Robo call thank you so first let's
take a look at the cloud scheduler tab
on the GCP console and you can see that
setting up a job is pretty
straightforward you can trigger jobs in
one of two ways you can either send a
data payload to an HTTP endpoint or you
can send it to a pub subchannel in most
cases I would recommend setting up your
jobs on a pub sub trigger the primary
reason is that pub sub channels are
secure by default meaning only
authorized google services can send data
to those channels in contrast HTTP
triggers are public to the world so
anybody that has that URL could
potentially trigger your function before
it's actually scheduled now the other
thing you'll notice here on the console
is that you set up the schedule using a
cron table this is just the standard
format for scheduling cron jobs and UNIX
based systems it's not something you
really need to know because there's
tools like crontab guru that allow you
to write out your schedule in a way that
a regular human can understand so now
we're going to write a cloud function
that is triggered on a pub sub message
and we'll hit the Twilio API to make a
voice call to my personal phone number
so we're here in the functions
environment and the only special thing
I've done is installed Twilio x' node
client library then I've also added a
series of environment variables to our
function for the to-and-from phone
numbers and also the client API keys all
that information is contained on the
Twilio dashboard I'm not really going to
get into that because I just want to set
the
up as an example so we can schedule it
on a time interval from that point we'll
go ahead and take our API keys and
initialize that Twilio client and then
we'll set up a cloud function that's
triggered on a specific pub/sub topic
any time a message is sent to this topic
this cloud function will be invoked
you'll want to make a note of the topic
you choose because you'll need that when
setting up the cloud scheduler we can
make this an async function and then
we'll use that Twilio client to make a
phone call which just needs a two and a
from' number then we can give it a
script which is a URL that needs to be
saved somewhere with some XML data I'll
show you that in just a second here and
that's pretty much all the code that's
necessary to build your own robocall or
what's Willie Oh obviously there's a lot
more we can do here but we'll cover that
in a future video then just to show you
what that XML looks like it's called
twimble format and it has basically just
a script that your bot will say when the
user picks up the phone the next step is
to just deploy our functions and then
we'll set up a scheduled job to run them
on a time interval now the next thing
we'll do is go into the GCP dashboard
and we'll create the topic that we just
registered this cloud function for so I
actually changed the name of my trigger
to call my phone and if you've deployed
your cloud function you should see that
you have one subscriber after you create
this topic and if you want to test it
out now you can just send a message to
this topic and you should get Twilio
calling your phone after a couple
seconds that's how the function gets
invoked but we want this to happen say
every five minutes or so let's go back
to crontab guru and we'll figure out the
pattern to send a message every five
minutes go ahead and copy that and then
go back to the cloud scheduler tab on
GCP you'll first need to give the job a
name and then we can paste in the cron
table into that frequency field then the
last step is to set the target as
pub/sub and then we'll have it point to
our call my phone topic now every five
minutes on the hour you should get a
call from Twilio reminding you to have a
great day and a couple of other nice
things about this interface is that you
can trigger your jobs to run early by
just clicking the Run Now button and you
can also view the logs to make sure that
they're running on the schedule that you
intended
all in all this is a very useful new
tool to have and I look forward to
building some integrations with it in
the future I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there if this video helped you
please like and subscribe and if you
want to take your development to the
next level consider becoming a pro
member at angular firebase comm you'll
get access to all kinds of exclusive
content designed to help you build and
ship your app faster thanks for watching
and I will talk to you soon